شاكيرا تنتقم من خيانه بيكي باغنيه وبي كي
يحولها لمكسب والعراقيون يسخرون من
دبلوماسيه عراقيه لا فهموا منصبها ولا
فهمه اصلا ايش بتقول وفي سابق لا يفعلها
الا عبد المجيد حفلان فل في موسم الرياض
وحفل ثالث قادم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
الانترنت حول العالم
والسبب اغنيه النجمه اللي متصدر الاخبار
والعناوين من وقت اطلاقها ويمكن نقدر
نسميها نوع من انواع الانتقام الموسيقي
الاكثر قوه صراحه ومن وقت ما نزلت بتحقق
ارقام قياسيه فالاغنيه ترند رقم واحد في
العالم على يوتيوب وللقان عليها ما يزيد
عن 110 مليون مشاهده خلال ثلاث ايام بس
لكن ليش انا سميتها انتقام موسيقي لانه
كلماتها ببساطه نوع من الانتقام والرسائل
المبطنه للاعب الاسباني جيرال بيكي واللي
انفصلت عنه شاكيرا السنه الماضيه بعد
علاقه اكثر من 10 سنين كان الناتج منها
حتى في ولدين وسبب الانفصال كان خيانه
شاكيرا مع موظفه في احدى شركاته او هذه هي
القصه المتداوله او المعتمده وكان رايح
ينتهي الحال فيهم في المحاكم بخصوص حضانه
الاولاد وامور اخرى لكنهم نجحوا انهم
ينهلوا الامور بالتسويه من وقت الانفصال
شاكيرا ساكته تماما وما تكلمت في اللي صار
ابدا وبيكا كمان ما صرح او اتكلم في شيء
لكن في كل مكان داير مع صاحبه الجديده
وصورهم وهم في احضان بعض في كل مكان
شاكيرا من الاول ساكته ويبدو انه اختارت
تقول كل اللي في قلبها عن طريق الاغنيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
استاذ مكه
[موسيقى]
طيب انا اي حد زي حالتي يعني ما بتكلم
اسبانيا مو فاهم وين الانتقام هيكون في
الموضوع بس انا خليني اوريكم فين واترجم
لكم بعض اجزاء الاغنيه يعني جمل تحديدا
شاكيرا بتقول في الاغنيه انا كثير عليك
وعلى شان كده انت رحت لاحد من حجمك وقيمتك
ما راح ارجع لك لو بكيت وتوصلت وبتقول
كمان يا ريت مثل ما بتدرب جسمك في الجيم
تدرب عقلك كمان وبتمنى لك التوفيق مع
بديلتي المفترضه وبتقول انا بقيمه اثنين
من بنات ال 22 شاكيرا للتذكير عمرها 45
سنه وصحبه بيكي الجديده عمرها 23 سنه
وقالت كمان بدلته الفراري
بتنجوكس بيكاسو صغيره كيوت كده من الانتاج
والفراري طبعا معروفه وكاسيو ساعه ممكن
نقول سعره في متناول المعظم على عكس يعني
ساعات الفاخره
وبك اكيد كمان ما عجب المقطع يعني او ما
عجبت الاغنيه فالاثنين اجتمعوا احبوا يعني
يستفيدوا من الموقف ويعطونا درس في فن
اقتناص الفرس
ان
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
ههه
[ضحك]
بث مباشر مع اعضاء الدوري الانجليزي
شركه كاسيو عليه اكثر من 200,000 شغال نكت
ومسخره على شاكيرا
رينو كمان حبه تستفيد في نشرت اعلان
السياره في تغريده بكلمات من اغنيه شاكيرا
وعلى الباب رقم 22 اللي شاكيرا غنت له
وهشتاقات من كلمات الاغنيه كمان
اليوتيوب حسن سليمان ابو فيلا صديق
نفتفعلكم هو من المؤثرين قولا وفعلا
ودائما بيسال تسخير شهرعته في عمل الخير
السنه الماضيه مثل هذه الايام شارك في
النسخه الثانيه من فعاليات اجمل شتاء في
العالم وشارك في لنجعل شتاءهم ادفى واللي
فيها قدر يجمع 11 مليون دولار في 12 يوم
ودخل موسوعه جينيس بعد ما فضل في غرفه
زجاجيه وفاتح بث مباشر الى ان جمع المبلغ
وكثر تفاعلكم غطينا مع المشوار كامله
السنه هذه ابو فله مشارك في مسابقه كنوز
اجمل شتاء واللي بتيجي من ضمن فعاليات
اجمل شتاء في العالم
وهذه المسابقه بتعتبر اكبر مسابقه سياحيه
من نوع وبتقدر قيمه جوائزها بمليون درهم
ورح تكون موزعه ضمن 51 كنز في مختلف مناطق
دبي السياحيه وكل احد موجود في الامارات
يقدر يشارك في هذه المسابقه والهدف منها
غير اجوائز الماديه هو ابراز طبعا اهم
الوجهات السياحيه والترفيه في الامارات
والتعريف بثقافتها وتاريخها وتراثها
وامس السبت انطلق البث المباشر لابو فله
من حسابه الشخصي على يوتيوب ومتواجد في
القريه العالميه في دبي ورح يفضل البث
شغال الى ان يتم العثور على 51 كنز وبفل
ضمن البث راح يعرض فيديوهات ودللات بتساعد
المشاركين في المسابقه للعثور على اماكن
الصناديق او الكنوز طبعا المبالغ اللي في
الصناديق مختلفه من واحد لاخر والتحدي
الاكبر هو الوصول للكنز اللي فيه 500,000
درهم ومن بعد ما يتم العثور على الكنز
بيتوجه حامل الصندوق القريه العالميه يتم
فتحه واعطاء الكنز اللي فاز في خلي ينضم
لنا اليوتيوب
معنا فله
يا مرحبتين يا هلا عرفنا على زميلك الي
معك كمان
صاحبي
كانت شغلانه اجلسنا نتابع العداد والفلوس
بتتجمع السنه كيف الوضع انت بدات امس
فعليه صحيح
وربع تقريبا او جده
تقريبا هي الفكره بكل بساطه قاعدين لمده
60 ساعه 51 جائزه متنوعه من من اصغر جائزه
الين النصف مليون درهم حاليا تقريبا مره
تقريبا يوم وربع نصف الجواز راحت او اكثر
من نصف الجواز اا اتوقع بكره راح يلعب
الحمد لله وقاعد الفكره بكل بساطه قاعد
تسوي شيء ترفيه انت جرحتي كل شيء
قاعد يسوي قاعد يسوي شيء ترفيه جميل ممتع
مع الناس
اللي ما بيشوفوا البث وان شاء الله
هيشوفوا البث بعد هذه المقابله للي ما
بيشوفوا البث اشرح لي مثلا
المتسابقين وهم ايش بيسووا احكي لي مثلا
قصه من القصص اللي صارت احد من اللي فازوا
جميل احد من اللي فازه بكل بساطه اللي
قاعد يسوي هنا 51 جائزه منتشره في جميع
الامارات اللي قاعد يسوي فاتحين البث اللي
عليه المشاهد يسوي من انه يتابعون واللي
عايشه في الامارات وايضا خارج الامارات في
جوائز اللي خارج الامارات
داخل الامارات اللي يسوونه اللي يتابعونا
البث يشوفون الادله اللي قاعد من عرضها في
البث ويروحون ويروحون الاماكن السياحيه
اماكن تكون جميله واحنا نعرف الحين حاليا
في اجمل شيء اجمل الشتاء يروح اماكن
السياحيه ويروح الاماكن الجميله ويشوف
التعليمات بالضبط
اوك مثلا في دليل حتى مثلا ان يكون او في
العين مثلا يكون فوق جبل حفيد مثلا وانه
يكون مثلا فوق جبل حفيد في البوابه او في
الدخله وهكذا التعليمات تكون رؤوس اغنام
ان مثلا او في مثلا احلى وحده قالت مثلا
تروح للبايك دي اكس في بايك وتروح لتوصل
للسد لا تدخل بالنفق او تقريبا
هذه تقريبا 20 سياره الى 30 سياره وقفت في
الميدان وصارت زحمه الى القصه
احد بيروح في نفس الوقت يعني
نعم نعم هذه المتعه ان عباره عن تنافس
جميل جدا وانه يسوون تجربه يعني في منهم
اللي سواه جديده وفي منهم اللي متعودين
فيها في التجربه هذه لان في كثير من
الفايزين اصلا اغلب الفايزين يعرفون
الاماكن اول ما يشوف ان المكالمات
انا قدامي في البث المباشر انت طالع عادي
بس رجعت الان اوكي صوره ارجع تتحركت همم
بس عشان كمان الناس اللي بيتابعونا الان
نحنا بنبس على شاشه العربيه وجاسين بنبص
عبر حسابك كمان الخاص المقابله شايفه
صورتي منور في في البلد
يا مرحبا الله يعطيك العافيه منوره دائما
في كل مكان الله يخليك طيب المهم المهم
الجائزه الكبيره
اه النص مليون الى الان اعلى ثلاث جوائز
الى الان نصف مليون و150,000 وال 50,000
درهم الى الان ما حد جابها بس حاليا
تقريبا في 10 اشخاص الى الان ما الجو
عندهم العشر صناديق راح يجون راح يشوف اذا
راح يفوزون بالمبلغ وهو وهي حظ صناديق
الرقم نشوف شو راح يطلع لك طيب انت شخصيه
يعني انت عارف مثلا جميل
[موسيقى]
هم الاثنين فاضل يعني طيب ممتاز هذه
المعلومه اللي قلت لي اياها هلا انه رقم
مدير اعمالك عندنا فهنتواصل الان اول ما
نخلص البث معه
هنشوف فريق تفاعلكم رايح في التراجر هانت
معكم كمان بنبحث عن الجواب الله يعطيك
العافيه يارب
ما شاء الله
[ضحك]
جميعا الله يرزق الجميع
اهلا من جديد في مقطع منتشر لمسؤول عراقيه
او على الاقل هكذا عرفت عن نفسها في
مقابله تلفزيونيه هذا المقطع عامل الكثير
من الضجه والاسباب كثيره اولا
تعرفون عن حضرتك
يعني ملف المؤتمرات والعلاقات الثنائيه
مسؤوله مديره يعني ملف المؤتمرات
والعلاقات الثنائيه
دكتوره زينب مسؤوله او مسؤوله مديره ملف
المؤتمرات والعلاقات الثنائيه اسم القسم
يعني بحد باتو غريب صراحه ما نسمع قبل لكن
اكيد لازم نسمع فين هذا القسم موجود
يعني ملف المؤتمرات والعلاقات الثنائيه
بالقنصليه العراقيه بجمهوريه اسطنبول
طيب القنصليه العراقيه في جمهوريه اسطنبول
الدكتوره زينب وضحت انها مسؤوله قسم
المؤتمرات والعلاقات الثنائيه في القنصليه
العراقيه في جمهوريه اسطنبول
اذا ما شفته يعني تنوعت ردادت يعني فعل
العراقيين بينضحك وتنكيت على جمهوريه
اسطنبول اللي ما احد سمع عنها قبل
وتساؤلات عن مين تكون هذه الدبلوماسيه ومن
عينها ايش هذا القسم اصلا طبعا في كلام عن
الفساد ووضع الخارجيه الصعب احنا رحنا
بحثنا وصلنا لان المقطع من مارس 20 22
وكان متصور خلال فعاليات ملتقى في اسطنبول
كان اسمه الملتقى التركي العربي لمستلزمات
وتكنولوجيا البناء والاستثمار والمشاريع
العقاريه ايش سبب انتشاره الان هذا المقطع
مو معروف لكن العراقيين من الدورين
وبالالام واثار غضبهم او علاقه يعني خلينا
نقول حفيظهم
في مقطع فيديو منتشر على المنصات المتداول
بشكل كبير جدا والفيديو لوزير روماني خلال
مقابله تلفزيونيه على الهواء
طيب يعني مو سهوه ولا سرحان شويه ولا شيء
لا يعني
رجال دخل في غفوه غفوه واستغراق يعني
الشخير حق وزير الزراعه السبع في البلد
كلها او يعني او ذحين معاها ان تشتري
المقطع بهذه الطريقه صراحه حول العالم
كمان انسى وبدل ما الموضوع الحلقه كان عن
التاثير السلبي للحرب في اوكرانيا
وتاثيرها على مزارعين رومانيا تحول
الاهتمام لشخير الوزير المهم المذيعه وسط
الضحك باقي الضيوف اللي كانوا معها على
الهواء قدرت تتدارك الموقف وتنقل لضيف اخر
وقالت انه راح ترجع تتصل فيه مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
موسم الرياض مولع الدنيا طبعا بفعاليات
وحفلاته ونجومه مليان حفلات طبعا مختلفه
جدا امس كان في حفله جامعه كارول سماحه
ومروان خوري وديانا حداد مروان خوري ومن
قبل الحفله كان وعد الجمهور واعلن عبر
حسابه على تويتر انه راح يقدم اغنيه جديده
اهداء للسعوديه ونشر كلماتها كمان وفي
الحفل اللي غناها على البيانو وتابعها
وشاركها الكثير من السعوديين وعلى راسهم
معالي المستشار تركي ال الشيخ
في البحر العربي
تلج الراس فوشتاق لميادي بياضات جايب لك
حب من عنا
ومن
نا شايفين الحق وداريه
[موسيقى]
شط البحر العراني
النجم عبد المجيد عبد الله كمان احيا
حفلتين استثنائيتين في ليلتين وراء بعض
الخميس والجمعه حفلات استثنائيه من كل
النواحي مثل ما تعودنا منه اقبال جنوني
على التذاكر وتفاعل كبير خلال الحفل وبعده
طبعا كمان التفاعل والطلب كان لدرجه تم
الاعلان فيها عن الليله الثالثه لعبد
المجيد عبد الله هتكون يوم 20 يناير
والتذاكر ستطرح قريبا والموضوع وصل لهم
علي المستشار تركي ال الشيخ طلب من اللي
حضر ما يرجع يشتري تذاكر ويعطي فرصه لغيره
لانه عارف طبعا انه معجمي عبد المجيد
مستعدين يروحوا يحضروا 10 ايام وراء بعض
صوت عبد المجيد عبد الله راح نختم حلقاتنا
اليوم وانا اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله
في امان الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جرح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومسيت من عمري اناديلك
من يشبهك
الرياضه
كيفهم جمال عجيب
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ليه